Welcome to Google Developers Show
My name is Nicolas Bortolotti and in this emission
Are we immersed in an ocean of Data?
We'll talk about Massive Data Analysis in our
"Reversed Focus" section.
We'll connect to BigQuery, we'll take large clusters of large data banks,
and we'll process them.
We'll also have our
"News and Updates" section
"Latam in your hands"
and "Android Microscope".
Welcome to our "Reversed Focus" section.
Here we'll
analyze an app.
First, we'll show it and then
we'll analyze its code of implementation.
In this particular case we'll show a solution
that connects with BigQuery. We'll generate
an application
that will be hosted in App Engine
that will connect to BigQuery
where will analyze a set of massive Data.
Then will take this information
and we will
render and display it using visualization API and a graphic of Google.
Let's run our application.
As you can see here
we have our browser and Google App Engine Launcher.
Let's locate our app inside Google App Engine Launcher.
As you can see, the app
is named DashBoard-Bigquery, here we have it...
available.
Let's run inside App Engine Launcher
the "Run" button.
This way it will run and compile the application. Let see how our application is working.
Our application is compiled and executed correctly.
Let's navigate through our app. We have 2 options: one is to use our "browse" button
and the other one is to
put "localhost" in the specific port, inside the browser.
Lets use the "browse" button.
By clicking on the browse button we'll go directly to our browser.
As you can see, the application is running on the localhost on the 19080 port.
This port is dynamic.
. Of course, it corresponds to
to the configuration that Google App Engine Louncher has.
As you can see we already have our chart that displays the information coming from BigQuery.
We can also
visualize more information using Chrome tools
to visualize how the Java Script is rendered correctly.
The app
executes a query and returns it to BigQuery,
and embeds the data
into a graph using Visualization API.
We developed an application using Python, the Python SDK for App Engine,
the connection to the BigQuery API and then the final rendering using Visualization API and Google charts.
Now we get into the code
and we will see in detail how this application is built
this app that has many files.  We'll analyze 3 of them that are very important:
An application in App Engine using Phyton.
We have a configuration file that is APP.jamel.
We'll see it quickly.
We'll see how is built. We'll have a .python file.
Let's check the main.phy,
And finally we'll take a look at
the HTML file.
This is the final file that renders the application,
and the graphic that we saw before.
Let's see the application settings.
Let's go inside our app.jamel file.
In this files,
all the essential attributes are placed for our application settings.
Let's see them.
Let's see the libraries we imported which is fundamental in this explanation.
As you can see in the configuration file that we have,
the "aplication" atribute that gives the name to
to the app when we display it
in the remote version,
the phyton runtime.
We also have the handlers management,
the static files management,
The generic handler management that we'll use
is set for the entire range of IP in the main. application.
And finally what is important here are also the libraries we are importing from the SDK with
micro frameworks.
In this case web ad 2 y jinga 2 as fundamental elements.
Let's leave our settings.
and let's analyze
the key file, the one that gives sense to all the application.
Here we have our main.phy
Let's see the imports
that we're using.
Jinga 2 and web ad 2 and we are also using simple jason
to shape a jason file that
the graphic will take
after the query to BigQuery.
Then we have generic imports,
and as you can see in the first part of the app
we have some froms
that represents
the integration wit the API of BigQuery.
So we have to do an integration
to the APIs, and in this particular case
to the BigQuery APIs. Remember that the application is an application on App Engine,
that will connect to BigQuery and will get\
the query to this massive set that we are proposing.
In this part we have a decorator, that will let to take
the secret to connect to the API and consult BigQuery.
Then we have the construction of the service.  In this case on
BigQuery version 2.0. Then we use some variables
to set the project, the dataset and finally the query.
Let's make a simulated query
to a database of Wikipedia,
we are actually making the massive data set
but then we can implement any data set.
In this case we'll use a public data set
and in this case Wikipedia that is a massive data set.
Then we have jinja settings which will allow us
to take data in App Engine application and embed it in the HTML template.
Then we have our main application that is the panel.
Remember that we are trying to represent a panel with graphics
to see variants of the massive data set queries.
So in this particular case
we put to work the setting and the micro framework Jinja.
Then we go the the handler, using web ad2
where we do specifically the implementation of this program.
To protect ourselves from the exceptions, we are making the query within the try
and taking its answer.
As you can see here, we are running the answer
with the variables of the project and the specific query
which we set in the first of the lines.
After this we are making a very simple configuration
to take this data from BigQuery and shape them so our chart can display it properly.
So we're representing a schema with a column with ID, a column with name and values,
that is what we have in this line.
Now w're setting some definitors
to work the graphic and finally we iterance the query coming from BigQuery
to inject the data in this new
scheme that we are representing
to finally flow this data into the jason file that will embed inside the chart
using Visualization API.
Here we're doing the iterance,
in this segment, we're building the jason file.
as we said before, with the implementation of simple jason.
Then what you are seeing in this part which is called template valuest
is using the bypass to go through Jinja 2 to the HTML file.
Finally what we're seeing here in this last part, is injecting these data
in a file that is named index.html,
finally the exception handling and our handler webad2 for which the application is running.
This is part of the main configuration file, now let's see
how these data flows from BigQuery to get displayed in that chart that we saw.
We'll see this in the second part of our "Reversed focus" section.
We're now in our "News and Updates" section. Here we take a look at the latest news
of the technological world,
the main features  of this technological awakening in Latin America.
Let's see two news and let's comment about them
The first has to do with public warnings and the new crisis map
to natural disasters in Mexico.
This is very important because it uses open data that is our topic for this emission.
You know how important this type of element is
in countries with high risk of natural disasters such as Mexico.
It is very interesting have it available and use it.
Natural disasters can be for example: earthquakes, volcanoes here is very common,
and in this particular case is now available for everyone to visualize.
Thanks to the collaboration also expressed
in Google's blog for Latin America: googleamericalatinablog.blogspot.com.mx
These data also is available thanks to the collaboration of institutions such as the Digital Strategy Lecturer coordinator,
National Chief of the Office of the Presidency of the Republic,
and other institutions like Conagua Conapred, the Federal Electricity Commission (CFE) and Green Angels,
that presented along with Google this new feature.
Let's go to our second news that envolves the techonological world.
This will be of great value for you that follows all the updates. This is an interesting feature
that Google developers team propose in: developer.google.com/fit.
Google fit! How important is to do sports!
As an enthusiastic developer
you must also do some workout!
And in this particular case, Google propose
an interesting challenge, to let us
develop for Fit! And in this particular case is very interesting because
the SDK will allow us to work with different types of sensors.
The case for watches or wearable devices that can be sensing when you do sport.
So you can take that information
process it and get interesting values.
You can also collect data of the sporting world as we are seeing and help the user
to make a Tracking and follow they daily training.
So now is being launched the new Google SDK Fit and we shared it with you!
This new technological advancement!
Now we return to  our "Reversed Focus" section and we will see the rendering of data.
So, we've analyzed the main part of our program for massive data inquiry.
So let's now analyze our  index.html that we have here.
We go back to our application, we go inside our code and we can see
that this file is actually a traditional HTML.
We're now seeing the basic structure, where we have a header,
its header is standard as well.
We have a title that we named "Visualization panel" using BigQuery,
Here we have the configured java Script,
that will allow to use a Google
chart through Visualization API
to place the data and view, in this case, in a scenario of columns.
Here we have the  Java Script. Let's analyze it.
Here, in the initial load, we have the visualization and the corechart,
then, in the implementation of the program in Java Script we have a variable data, and the key is here
because is parte of the jinja template
in which we put the data of the query that comes from BigQuery with that format in Jason,
to the chart.  We also put a
safe attribute so we won't have problems with the format of the data.
Then we have the Data variable that propose a Data Table and embeds that variable data
inside that Data Table, and this is now part of the traditional scenario that you could find
to visualize data in a chart.
Finally we have here a standard function of visualization,
that propose a column chart, and it also embeds inside the visualization attribute,
in the traditional HTML that we'll have and that I will show you at the end of the code.
Then we have a very traditional setting of some attributes in which you can place
many more, where we finally name our graphic as "columns panel".
Remember that the graphic brings that massive data of the query from BigQuery.
This information ends with oncall or onload callback.
This is the callback that we use to visualize the graphic.
In the body of my HTML file we have the ID visualization where we'll load
our graphic. Just like that we connect to BigQuery from App Engine in this particular case,
we query millions of registers or rows of data,
we obtain this result, we process it,
as we showed you and finally we embed in an HTML through a template.
So this is the resolution for our "Reversed Focus" section.
Welcome to "Latam in your hands"
We remind you that "Latam in your hands" propose to know the opinion of experts
in all our continent. In this particular case, we have the presence of
"Codenando México". This team of hackers that works on Open Data
and propose an interesting perspective that we'll show you here
in this unique section that we call "Latam in your hands". Let's hear
to "Codeando México" team
Hi I'm Juan Pablo Escobar  founder and director of "Codeando Mexico".
We are a nonprofit organization working with open data,
civic Hacking in Mexico.
How did we start and why?
Suddenly we came to the need to see what would happen if we changed a bit
the goal of what we were doing as developers and we focus
on bigger issues of the society.
I'm in chage of Community and Strategy in Codeando Mexico.
People are seeing the value of Open Data in communities of people not only in technology but also journalists, researchers.
Many people are seeing the value of using open data
as a tool to create solutions that solve real problems in the city.
And we realized it was a super important need to have a place where the developer
could use the public data of the
country in an organized way.
In 2013 we proposed a project where every citizen, organization, company
or even the government could share public data.
The government has responded and is taking some very specific initiatives to open data
so people can reach it.
One of those initiatives is: datos.gob.mx
Each day is growing with more available data
so developers and entrepreneurs can use it
to create value and improve mexican society.
Developers and also companies
like Google are supporting the project with the development
for open data.
Like how to change this mainset and start being more agile in the part of civic technolog.
Or how do you go from a mockup to a prototype of you app in Android.
And instead of having a server that could take you hours, now is so simple with Compute Engine.
and have any civic app that you wish.
We've been using Compute Engine,
Cloud Storage, and it has helped us to better understand how we can focus
on innovating, because with Google support
we can trust in the infrastructure.
Fortunately Open Data gives us an easier way to work with this type of platform.
We are designing, with Google support,
using Compute Engine, a much better response
when we have to process all the data.
There comes a time to really explore what we can do with them and what we can change
in the country. The government must build technology
that has value and impact in the society. We must be involved as Developers
with the government and companies to keep growing.
Very interesting the perspectivo of "Codeando Mexico".
Here, in "Latam in your hands" we also have the opinion
of different people and now we have a very important perspective, the testimonial of the Federal Government
of Mexico,
That releases the data and is promoting this exciting movement on open data.
Let's see the vision that is proposed by the Federal Government of Mexico.
Hi I'm Rodolfo Wilhelmy, I am director of open data
for Coordination in the National Digital Strategy
in the Government of Mexico, and what we are doing is the open data initiative, among other things.
We seek that all information contained in the government of the Republic is made public,
in: datos.gob.mx
with the intention of you developers and entrepreneurs can use this data
to add value.
Google has been very close to these initiatives. We have been using many open and free apps
from Google, that has helped as a lot.
We're using Google Refine, Open Refine and  BigQuery, because
when you're working on open data
you have to work in the quality of that data.
To achieve this, we've been working directly with the secretariats,
and government agencies, in order to help and give them some advice, some guidance
to improve the publication of open data.
Open Refine has been of great value,
We taught them how to use it, to clean and improve
the quality of data bases.
And they loved the tool, we received a lot of positive feedback.
Now we're exploring BigQuery
to deliver data massively, scaled
and in that sense it is very helpful because it is very difficult for a secretariat
o a government agency
to have APIs o such a scalable infrastructure like Google APIs.
So this will serve us very well and it will be a great benefit
for all the community of developers,
because now we'll be able to have APIs of great quality!
This was "Latan in your hands"
We invite you to share with us
who would be your references!
You can share it in: Google.com\+desarrolladoresgoogle
Share it with us, because Latin America is in your hands!
See you in the next show, don't miss it and remember, keep developing!